foreign
[Music]
fights for a very talented animators
show of their skills their patience and
their Cutthroat determination for
quality and there's no better way to
display that than by showcasing fights
with such animator Flex can be seen the
most hand-to-hand combat we're just a
few years into the new decade but here
we go my top 10 hand-to-hand fights in
anime so far first up is yujiro versus
kakukayo
yeah
it's been a good while since Bach you
felt like you had a social media
presence and I think that that's too bad
it was once a time a couple of years ago
when these martial arts shows seem to be
hitting their stride and one leading the
charges none other than this
continuation to the decently popular
childhood series well if you're a 90s
kid like me that is and if you need one
clip to show you how awesome Barky can
be and what it's all about you can Feast
your eyes on this fight between yujiro
and Kaku Kayo the show's just as wild as
you'd have guessed by seeing this fight
it's over the top it's really violent
and has all sorts of twists and turns
that you'll only really see in anime it
also helps this fight Pit's two of the
strongest characters in the show gaio
may have gotten destroyed when it's all
said and done but you can't say that he
didn't put on a good showing for yujiro
and the fans for that matter
foreign
ER had the benefit of running smoothly
over the course of a season ravaged by
production delays all eyes were on this
Niche title and with a spotlight on it
is Sean brightly and made a statement
that season and that's largely thanks to
this attention-grabbing fight that
happened early on glipley is all about
making First Impressions with its dark
atmosphere surprisingly amazing fight
choreography and a plot that grips you
hard and keeps you watching true to form
the strongest part of the glibeneer
anime is in the first half with its
engaging end goals and the fights that
people compare to the big guns no one
expected a banger like this from Pine
Jam but we can all tell that there was
much love put into this adaptation the
fighting was fast and furious and it
quickly established what our heroes are
all about it's no-nonsense and that's
the beauty of it that makes it a good
compliment for the atmosphere the show's
going for
good enough
broader versus executioner is also a
nice little fight in a title that rose
out of nowhere
Awkward on my drive in contrast took
quite a longer time to make its Mark
it's got a good atmosphere and quickly
set the tone for what it wants to do
however it took a while to come into its
own and a bit a large part of its late
rally into popularity with the
escalation of stakes coupled with
amazing fights like this it's a similar
case with glyphenir now that think about
it actually amongst the high octane
fights it had one conflict that stood
out to me was brawler versus executioner
it's a fight that the animation team
perfectly nailed and it really captured
the intense stylish action that became
akodama drives claim to fame while it
started out involving swords the two of
them quickly got into it and let their
fists do the talking the rain and the
music only added to the atmosphere and
you quickly get sucked in thinking this
is some climactic fight that just caps
off a series but it is only halfway
through the series and there's still so
much more to come from akudama Drive
[Applause]
Vivi vs Hugo is next on the list
baby though had some momentum with it
right from the get-go it helps that it's
attached to one of the community's most
beloved authors being the brainchild of
the fan favorite re-zero author it does
feel quite strange to see him take the
dive into sci-fi but whatever because it
really worked out so well in the end and
don't forget the fight the fights man I
like the series primarily for its themes
and its overall production quality and
pacing everything looks so good so when
you put in that level of quality with
this fast-paced fighting then you know
only good things are going to happen the
fight has a lot of emotional weight
behind it and it's simply a gift to
anime fans with the Fast and Furious
fighting the crisp animation and the
music that adds so much to the scene
sound direction is something that people
often Overlook in terms of evaluating
fights and just think that it does so
well in complementing this one going
from a solemn set of tunes to the
crescendo and an Abrupt and decisive end
where the fight scene reaches its
Tipping Point it's a beautiful thing to
witness BB's more than just fights
though but if I manage to get you
interested through this showcase then
I'll be more than glad
[Music]
Valhalla vs Tokyo Manji gives us some of
the best that Tokyo Avengers has to
offer
what good would a show be about gangs
without some of the most adrenaline
pumping fights where the people go down
and dirty and just beating the hell out
of each other this encounter from Tokyo
Avengers pretty much tells us what the
show has in the bag as far as action
sequences go it's not every day we get
to see The multi-man Rumble in anime so
this conflict has that extra big fight
feel stemming from episodes of build up
and hype when we get to the actual
action it's great it's wild chaotic and
intense in all the good ways all that
you'd expect from gang Warfare done well
is here and it's got some insane moments
that became some of the most memorable
scenes that the show gave us I'm pretty
sure Mikey or already a popular
character earned himself a lot more fans
following this fight and his performance
in it
Jin versus Davey is up next
adaptation God of high school is
polarizing to say the least there's a
lot of things that could have been
worked on in terms of the pacing the cut
content and the overall flow of the
story is seen in the anime still it did
maintain a pretty solid fan base
throughout its run because at the end of
the day it still does one thing
excellently to keep people hooked and
that's its fight the team never skimmed
his show in the awesome fight and their
spectacles in themselves gin vs Davey is
one of my favorite amongst the bunch in
addition to being an excellent fight
between people who have history it also
served to further their character arcs
some of the best stories are told in the
fights and as much as I talk down on how
God of high school paced itself a while
ago I can't help but feel Goosebumps
watching this fight unfold and how it
affected both combatants given mad props
to the anime team for making the fight
more and more exciting as it goes on to
be honest I really love the touch they
did towards the end with Shifting the
art star mid fight makes you feel the
increased in tension and it ended up
being a good indicator that the climax
was coming
here's an old face to shake things up
now Naruto shines in his batter against
ishiki
Naruto's batter against isiki the one
with baryon mode is more known for how
hard it hit Naruto fans heart it's got a
lot of implications to the story and it
serves as a perfect swan song for a much
beloved character everyone's so caught
up in the awesome Supernatural things
happening what I'd like to focus our
attention on is the physical combat bit
of this scene because in true boruto
fashion the anime team completely knocks
it out of the park in key events
involving the Legacy characters you can
feel the power in every blow Naruto
delivered each one serving as ample
payback for the previous fight he had
with ishiki and the two shake things up
by involving other moves in their
Arsenal for the hand-to-hand combat part
and those were all beautifully animated
for us to enjoy they also mix it up with
the magic powers but at its core this
confrontation is a splendid display of
hand-to-hand prowess it's definitely not
what most people remember out of Naruto
as a franchise I mean hey for everyone
cool daijutsu moment we have a dozen
moments of insane overpowered displays
of magic but the fight still serves as a
heart pounding kind of the versatility
of the franchise in terms of writing and
executing fights without feeling too
repetitive
Schwann vs wrath is here and we head
towards the end
remember how I was raving about Chinese
anime stepping up well here's another
sample fog Hill has some of the best
combat scenes I've seen in the past few
years folk Hill did have a short run I
mean it barely qualifies in the
traditional definition of a TV anime
with its episode count and I guess it
serves more as a short OVA or a movie
cut into several episodes in spite of
its short length though you could tell
that the team didn't half-ass this
project it's got so much to like if
we're talking about fights the bridge
fight was good but this one-on-one
encounter between two fighters it's got
everything that you'd want from a fight
tension eye-popping animation to pair
with the fighters movements across the
battlefield have some excellent voice
acting to top it off as well it's the
climax any viewer would dream of the
cool thing about this is that fog Hill
was actually made by a small team so
it's not inaccurate to say that
literally a dozen people animated this
spectacle but here we are a lot of love
for the craft as well as skill and
effort all come together and the results
they're really just spectacular
speaking of Niche anime though here's
Oya and the mask out stuking it out
[Music]
if you're on a master class in terms of
Animation then this is the fight for you
the great thing about beer-handed combat
is that it allows so much fluid motion
with the fighters getting so up and
personal with each other there's just so
many opportunities to lose yourself in
the Flurry of Blows and the Swift dance
that the combatants do this fight from
hitori noshita is simply insane if you
take those things into mind that's
definitely not those static images
standing around which the arms fire in
all directions type of thing this is
probably the most dynamic fighter
featured so far featuring a lot of full
body movement a lot of martial arts
moves a simple direction that makes
things a lot faster and more intense
than you're actually expecting it to be
I have featured this fight before but if
you've only started watching this
channel here's a tidbit for you the one
behind the choreography of this fight is
the one behind Naruto and Sasuke vs
momoshiki really awesome connections
that you think especially since we've
featured a boruto fight featuring Naruto
just a while ago
[Music]
nope
lastly we finish off with one of the
best moments from Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Yuji
and Toto versus Hanami
take the previous fight right with its
Sleek motion and Fast and Furious
fighting then add a bigger budget more
character elements at play and some
top-notch direct dig and then you end up
with this fight right here Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen has a lot of awesome fights and
this one is likely to be the one people
remember the first season four I mean
can you blame them for it it's just it's
just awesome you gotta love how Yuji and
Toto's chemistry get shown and as I've
said before this fight is the true
Testament the fruit of their friendly
Spar and growing relationship has been
built up in the previous episodes
incorporating Supernatural Powers with
hand-to-hand fighting has always looked
so good but when you add context to the
scene it drives my appreciation for this
battle up a notch we also get a great
finish and yet another memorable Gojo
moment towards the end of this fight but
I think it's best to leave that for
another day for now just Feast your eyes
on Peaks Shonen fighting courtesy of the
newest pillar in the ever-growing
history of actions Shonen
and that's it for my top hand-to-hand
fights for the years 2020 to 2023. if
you've got something more to share then
the floor is yours before I leave gotta
say thank you so much for watching so
stay safe stay awesome and I'll see you
next time